El vídeo de hoy ha sido posible gracias a
Masterworks.
Más sobre esto en un momento.
Los jerifaltes políticos y militares de China
anhelan sobre todo una cosa: reconquistar
Taiwán.
A su vez, en Taiwán cada vez son más los
que sueñan con lograr una independencia plena.
Y en Estados Unidos, bueno, digamos que esperan
que algún que otro traspié le impida a China
convertirse en una superpotencia de verdad.
Hablamos de un enorme juego de ajedrez.
Un juego geopolítico en el que ahora, la
tormenta de fuego, destrucción y aniquilación
que las huestes de Putin han lanzado sobre
Ucrania ha hecho saltar todas las alarmas.
De repente son muchos los países a lo largo
y ancho del mundo que han entendido una cosa:
Que incluso en pleno siglo XXI la guerra puede
estar mucho más cerca de lo que podríamos
haber imaginado.
Por supuesto, en todo esto Taiwán se lleva
la palma.
(La situación geopolítica, militar y estratégica
de Taiwán tiene muchas similitudes con Ucrania:
Tanto Rusia como China mantienen reivindicaciones
que, de una u otra forma, pasan por limitar
la soberanía de estos territorios.
Además, tanto Taiwán como Ucrania son países
que han intentado, con mayor o menor éxito,
forjar instituciones propias, relaciones con
Occidente y consolidar un sistema democrático.)
Pero empecemos por el principio.
Los taiwaneses empezaron a verle las orejas
al lobo cuando el régimen de Xi Jinping terminó
de un plumazo con la independencia que de
facto disfrutaba la antigua ciudad libre de
Hong Kong.
Ese fue para Taipei el primer aviso.
Ahora la invasión de Ucrania ha hecho saltar
de nuevo las alarmas.
Ha sido el segundo y quizás último aviso.
Y es que, veréis, durante décadas se ha
dado por hecho que el Ejército Popular de
Liberación chino no tenía la suficiente
capacidad como para invadir Taiwán y hacerse
con el control de la isla.
Sin embargo, según muchos expertos militares
eso podría cambiar muy pronto.
Dados los planes que China tiene actualmente
en marcha, para los años 2025-2027, el gigante
asiático podría estar listo para lanzar
su ofensiva.
Y por eso, en Taiwán están prestando mucha,
pero que muchísima atención a lo que está
ocurriendo en Ucrania.
(“La determinación y la resiliencia que
el pueblo de Ucrania ha mostrado a raíz de
la invasión rusa ha inspirado a Taiwán,
reforzando nuestro compromiso de defender
nuestra libertad.”
- Bi-khim Hsiao, representante de Taiwán
en EE.UU.)
Y, ojo, que no hablamos solo de palabras vacías.
La brutal invasión rusa ya ha hecho que el
gobierno de Taiwán comience a tomar medidas.
(Taiwán busca extender el servicio militar
obligatorio más allá de los 4 meses
El ministro dice al parlamento que se están
considerando propuestas y que se presentará
un plan este mismo año
La presión de Pekín sobre la isla y la guerra
de Rusia en Ucrania han suscitado un debate
sobre cómo potenciar la defensa - SCMP)
Ahora bien, más allá de los grandes titulares:
¿Qué lecciones puede extraer Taiwán de
Ucrania?
Qué puede y que no puede aprender el país
de Tsai Ing-wen del país de Volodymyr Zelensky?
Atentos.
[Pero antes…
Queremos contaros algo interesante.
Famosos, líderes políticos, titanes de la
industria, … Ahora más que nunca todos
ellos están poniendo su dinero en un activo
en particular: el arte.
Mientras que el SP500 lleva un 17% abajo desde
máximos y el IBEX35 también está en números
rojos a 1 y 5 años vista, el mercado del
arte se ha mostrado resistente.
De hecho, en mayo de 2022, las casas de subasta
han visto precios récord.
Christies, por ejemplo, vendió más de 800
millones de dólares en tan solo 7 días,
y las ventas en Sotheby’s de la colección
Macklowe registraron un récord total de ventas
de 922 millones de dólares.
Y es que, tal y como apuntaba el responsable
global de los servicios de asesoría en arte
y finanzas del Citi Private Bank, aún hay
mucha demanda de obras de arte por parte de
museos con renombre.
En otras palabras, que además de para decorar
mansiones, el arte puede ser una herramienta
más para proteger tu patrimonio - y de paso
poder sacarle un buen rendimiento.
Así que no nos sorprende que según Deloitte
el 85% de los gestores de patrimonio recomienden
el arte como un activo a incluir en nuestra
cartera.
Y con un nuevo millonario cada 17 minutos
en 2021, la demanda de obras de alto valor
sigue aumentando.
Así que tenemos una oferta limitada, y una
demanda creciente.
No parece una mala combinación.
La pregunta es, ¿cómo podemos aprovecharnos
de esta corriente sin tener que invertir millones
en un solo cuadro?
Con Masterworks puedes incluir obras de alto
valor en tu cartera por una fracción del
coste total, porque estarás invirtiendo la
cantidad que elijas en fracciones de una pintura.
La verdad que nos parece una idea revolucionaria,
y viendo cómo las obras que han vendido ya
han reportado un 30% neto de comisiones a
sus miembros, parece que además tienen buen
ojo para seleccionar piezas de arte.
Por supuesto, resultados pasados no garantizan
rendimientos futuros.
Si quieres echar un vistazo por ti mismo a
Masterworks, te dejo el link en la descripción
para conseguir acceso prioritario y saltarte
así la lista de espera.]
Dicho esto, continuemos.
1 (LECCIONES DESDE UCRANIA)
Ahora la guerra de Ucrania ha servido para
destacar dos ideas:
Primero, ha demostrado que el hecho de ser
más fuerte no siempre garantiza la victoria
militar.
Y segundo, que incluso aunque el país atacante
sea toda una potencia nuclear y un importantísimo
proveedor de suministros clave los aliados
occidentales pueden estar dispuestos a prestar
toda la ayuda necesaria para armar hasta los
dientes a un aliado que luche por conservar
su territorio y su independencia.
Y ojo, que esto era algo que hasta la invasión
rusa de Ucrania generaba muchas dudas.
Y, aún más.
Si los países occidentales se han volcado
con Ucrania, que básicamente es un exportador
de grano, imaginaos qué posición podrían
adoptar con el país que produce más de la
mitad de todos los semiconductores avanzados
que se usan en el mundo.
Y no lo decimos nosotros, lo dice el propio
presidente de Estados Unidos Joe Biden.
N2(Biden afirma que EE. UU.
Intervendría militarmente si China invadiera
Taiwán
Los comentarios durante la visita a Tokio
despiertan incertidumbre sobre si Estados
Unidos se está alejando de la política de
la "ambigüedad estratégica".
WSJ)
Pero más allá de Estados Unidos, estas son
algunas de las recetas que Taiwán puede estar
ya extrayendo de la experiencia ucraniana.
En primer lugar tenemos que tener en cuenta
que, al ser una isla, Taiwán corre un elevado
riesgo de ser asediada.
De hecho, antes de lanzar la propia ofensiva
militar, es muy probable que China utilizara
una combinación de técnicas de asedio con
acciones de guerra híbrida, como por ejemplo
ciberataques o sabotajes de todo tipo.
Pues bien, para resistir el asedio, y en base
a la experiencia de ciudades como Mariupol
o Kharkiv, lo primero que tiene que hacer
Taiwán es duplicar sus reservas de petróleo
para permitir que el ejército pueda mantener
su operativa.
(Actualmente la Ley de Administración del
Petróleo de Taiwán prevé que las reservas
de crudo asciendan a 30 días del consumo
medio del año anterior, esto supone aproximadamente
un millón de barriles diarios.
Ahora, tras la experiencia ucraniana, los
expertos militares están aconsejando que
Taiwán como mínimo duplique esas reservas
hasta los 60 días.
Además este almacenamiento debería situarse
en zonas altas y de forma dispersa por todo
el país, tanto para su protección contra
ataques de precisión como para que el petróleo
pueda seguir transportándose, gracias a gravedad,
incluso aunque se produzcan alteraciones en
el suministro eléctrico.
También, para garantizar el suministro eléctrico,
los expertos militares aconsejan la construcción
de múltiples generadores eléctricos de combustible
junto a los mismos depósitos.)
Asimismo, teniendo en cuenta que los puertos
podrían convertirse en objetivos prioritarios
para el invasor, el país debe prepararse
para recibir entregas over-the-shore, es decir,
sin tener que utilizar las infraestructuras
portuarias.
En total se estima que estas acciones podrían
costarle a Taiwán más de 4.000 millones
de dólares.
Pero tened una cosa clara: garantizar la provisión
de petróleo al ejército podría determinar
el rumbo de la guerra.
De la misma forma, los expertos también están
recomendando que el país incremente urgentemente
sus reservas de alimentos básicos hasta un
mínimo de 120 días de consumo, que construya
pozos de agua por toda la isla y que ponga
en marcha una red eficaz de internet vía
satélite.
(El internet de Starlink se convierte en un
salvavidas para los ucranianos
En Ucrania, la tecnología de Starlink ha
encontrado un lugar donde puede demostrar
su valía, especialmente si se usa de forma
distinta a la prevista.
A lo largo de la invasión, Rusia ha atacado
constantemente la infraestructura de comunicaciones
de Ucrania con armas militares y ataques cibernéticos.
- NBC Noticias)
La idea con este primer bloque de medidas
sería preparar a Taiwán para resistir el
tiempo suficiente como para que pudiera llegar
la ayuda internacional o para que China tire
la toalla.
Pero claro, además de la infraestructura,
esta meta necesita sobre todo garantizar una
defensa militar eficaz.
Y justo aquí llegamos a la segunda lección
que nos está dejando la invasión rusa: se
puede llegar a contener a un ejército superior.
Y para hacerlo tenemos que hablar necesariamente
del equipamiento militar y sobre todo de tres
ejes: la defensa balística, la defensa aérea
y la defensa marítima.
Y es que veréis, la guerra de Ucrania no
solo le está sirviendo de aprendizaje a Taiwán,
también a la propia China.
Por ejemplo, el gigante asiático se podría
haber dado cuenta de que para lograr una rápida
superioridad militar necesitaría arremeter
con una cantidad brutal de fuego antes de
llevar a cabo la invasión a gran escala.
Esto es algo que Rusia no hizo antes de invadir
Ucrania.
Pues bien, para poder hacer frente a este
más que probable escenario Taiwán tiene
que multiplicar su defensa contra misiles
balísticos y armas de precisión.
(Actualmente Taiwán ya tiene programado actualizar
sus 350 misiles Patriot PAC-3 y comprar 300
interceptores adicionales.
Probablemente tras la experiencia de Ucrania
el esfuerzo sea aún mayor.
Por ejemplo, se podría impulsar la compra
de drones y equiparlos con equipamiento de
guerra electrónica, lo que permitiría reducir
la precisión de los misiles guiados chinos.
Esto implicaría para el invasor un esfuerzo
militar y económico mucho mayor.
Incluso hay quien defiende en la isla presionar
a Estados Unidos para que despliegue su sistema
THADD en Taiwán.
Sin embargo, parece poco probable que en Washington
estuvieran dispuestos a hacerlo.
Cuando lo desplegaron en Corea del Sur se
produjo un enorme conflicto diplomático con
China)
Luego, Ucrania también ha mostrado cómo
impedir que el invasor se haga con el control
aéreo es algo posible y algo que además
puede resultar clave para ralentizar sus operaciones.
En esta línea, la defensa ucraniana se ha
caracterizado por estar organizada en capas,
haciendo que la potencia invasora no pueda
o le cueste mucho más conseguir la superioridad
aérea.
("Sin el control aéreo...
China sería incapaz de ejecutar casi cualquier
plan militar contra Taiwán.”
- Harry Halem y Eyck Freymann, analistas geopolíticos.)
Pues bien, Taiwán podría crear una primera
capa defensiva de mayor alcance y altitud
mediante los Patriot, una capa media con otras
baterías antiaéreas de menor precisión
y una última capa con sistemas antiaéreos
portátiles, es decir, los que pueden transportar
consigo los propios soldados.
Los conocidos como MANPADS.
Todos hemos visto en Ucrania el ejemplo de
los Stinger donados por la OTAN o los propios
Strela que ya tenían y que han servido para
derribar numerosos helicópteros, drones e
incluso algún que otro caza ruso.
Por último tenemos el caso de la defensa
marítima.
Por supuesto al tratarse de una isla este
punto cobra mucha importancia: para impedir
la invasión es fundamental que Taiwán logre
evitar los desembarcos y que China utilice
la línea de costa para atacar posiciones
en tierra.
Pues bien, aunque Ucrania carecía de una
fuerza naval, cosa que Taiwán evidentemente
sí tiene, hay algo que sí podría copiar:
la estrategia ucraniana de denegación del
mar.
(La denegación del mar es un término militar
que consiste en imposibilitar que el enemigo
utilice el mar para llevar a cabo un asalto
sin que al mismo tiempo eso implique el control
de las aguas.
Taiwán podría fijarse, por ejemplo, no solo
como Ucrania ha desplegado numerosas minas
marinas, sino sobre todo en lo importante
que puede resultar almacenar y desplegar misiles
antibuque y municiones guiadas de precisión
a lo largo de toda la costa del país en pequeños
depósitos difíciles de detectar para el
invasor.)
De hecho, así es como Ucrania logró hundir
el Moskva con sus misiles Neptune: pasando
desapercibido.
(El buque de guerra Moskva estaba ciego ante
el ataque con misiles ucranianos, según un
análisis
La tripulación del RTS Moskva (121) estaba
ciega y no estaba preparada para el ataque
con misiles ucranianos que hundió el buque
insignia de Rusia en el Mar Negro.
- USNI News)
(Odesa golpeada por misiles mientras Ucrania
afirma que ha hundido un segundo barco ruso
- The Guardian)
Además, la experiencia en la guerra de Ucrania
ha demostrado que el actual inventario de
Taiwán podría resultar claramente insuficiente.
Incluso, teniendo en cuenta noticias como
esta:
(Taiwán más que duplicará su capacidad
de producción anual de misiles ante las tensiones
con China
Taiwán planea más que duplicar su capacidad
de producción anual de misiles a cerca de
500 este año.
- Reuters)
Taiwán lleva ya tiempo mejorando su defensa
marítima, por ejemplo con la compra de 400
misiles antibuque Harpoon a Estados Unidos
y 25 radares para poder operarlos.
Estos misiles podrían ser capaces de golpear
a los barcos chinos poco después de que estos
salieran de puerto.
Pero los números parecen claramente insuficientes.
Hace falta más, mucho más para tener realmente
una fuerza de disuasión efectiva.
En tercer lugar, podemos destacar algo en
lo que Ucrania literalmente ha aplastado a
Rusia: la guerra por la narrativa y la comunicación.
Esto es algo en lo que Zelensky ha demostrado
ser todo un artista.
Si algo ha hecho Ucrania ha sido ganarse la
adhesión de la inmensa mayor parte de Occidente.
Sí, son las víctimas de la invasión, pero
eso no quiere decir que fuera coser y cantar.
Ucrania se ha presentado al mundo no solo
como la víctima de una invasión sino también
y sobre todo como un país que lucha por la
democracia, la apertura y los valores europeos.
Esto, amigos, ha hecho que no apoyar a Ucrania
sea de tan mal gusto que hasta la Unión Europea
se ha puesto manos a la obra.
Además en todo momento Zelensky defendió
que la victoria era posible si contaba con
el apoyo de occidente.
Es decir, hizo una atribución de responsabilidad.
Pues bien, Taiwán es el país con más derechos
civiles de toda Asia, un líder tecnológico
imprescindible y un importante aliado occidental.
Fortalecer la agenda exterior y sobre todo
convertirse en algo así como la Meca de la
Libertad y los derechos civiles podría ser
clave para, llegado el caso, contar con el
apoyo masivo y unánime de occidente.
Es algo de lo que ya os hablamos aquí, en
Visualpolitik, en un pasado vídeo sobre la
defensa de Taiwán.
Y por último, la cuarta clave tiene que ver
con la movilización general.
Sobre todo con las llamadas fuerzas de defensa
territorial, que fueron creadas a partir del
año 2015, y que están jugando un papel clave
en la defensa de Ucrania.
Hablamos de una especie de ejército de apoyo
bien organizado y que incluso se ha constituido
como una rama propia de las Fuerzas Armadas.
Un ejército que está compuesto por reservistas
y voluntarios que reciben entrenamiento y
que se encargan de tareas como, por ejemplo:
controlar la seguridad del territorio, brindarle
apoyo logístico a las tropas, inteligencia,
realizar emboscadas y operaciones de sabotaje
o, incluso, respaldar ágilmente las propias
acciones de combate del ejército profesional
con efectivos allí donde es necesario.
La idea es que la defensa sea mucho más densa
y, por tanto, que el invasor tenga mucho más
difícil controlar el territorio.
Este modelo ucraniano ha empezado a ser copiado
por Polonia y ahora hay quien piensa que Taiwán
podría hacer lo propio.
Sin embargo, esto podría llegar a ser muy
complicado.
Porque amigos, aquí es cuando entramos en
lo que quizás Taiwán no pueda aprender de
Ucrania.
Atentos.
(LO QUE TAIWÁN QUIZÁS NO PUEDA APRENDER)
Las fuerzas de defensa territorial han jugado
un papel fundamental en la resistencia de
Ucrania.
Y tiene sentido.
Como os decíamos, lograr que la defensa sea
mucho más densa en un territorio puede convertir
una invasión en una enorme pesadilla.
Al tiempo que el ejército profesional libera
recursos para poder centrarse en atacar al
enemigo.
Gracias a estas fuerzas, ciudades ucranianas
como Kyiv, Kharkiv, Odessa o Mykolayiv se
blindaron hasta el punto que los soldados
rusos no pudieron penetrar en ellas.
Sin embargo, a pesar de su gran papel, esto
es algo que quizás Taiwán no pueda copiar.
(En Taiwán sí existe un cuerpo de defensa
civil, pero lo cierto es que no está militarizado
y que depende enteramente de la policía.
Hablamos de un cuerpo que está pensado fundamentalmente
para colaborar en evacuaciones o ante desastres
naturales como terremotos, tifones o inundaciones.
Sus miembros no reciben ningún tipo de entrenamiento
con armas.
Y desde luego no es probable que sepan usarlas
por sí mismos.
Este es de hecho uno de los países del mundo
con la legislación más estricta respecto
a la posesión de armas, hasta el punto de
que incluso para comprarte una pistola de
pesca submarina necesitas un permiso policial.)
Y aunque existe el servicio militar, este
es muy corto, de apenas 4 meses, y hoy por
hoy no brinda un entrenamiento eficaz ante
una situación de guerra.
El caso es que, además, intentar convertir
esta fuerza civil en una especie de ejército
sería algo ilegal.
Y vale, ya sé lo que estaréis pensando.
Pero, Alberto, ¿no sería tan fácil como
decir…
pues cambiamos las leyes?
Pues… no, lo cierto es que no.
Hoy sería ilegal y no parece existir la voluntad
política suficiente como para cambiar esa
situación.
Al menos así están las cosas hoy en día.
Pero llegados hasta aquí, turno para ti:
¿debería Taiwán cambiar esto y apostar
por la resistencia civil armada?
¿Debería el país de Formosa construir toda
una insurgencia como hicieron los ucranianos
entre 2014 y 2022?
¿Crees que Taiwán lograría resistir una
invasión china al menos con tanto éxito
como lo está haciendo Ucrania?
Déjanos tu opinión aquí debajo, en los
comentarios.
Y si te ha gustado este vídeo no olvides
darle like y suscribirte a nuestro canal para
no perderte ninguna de las novedades que están
por llegar.
Una vez más gracias por estar ahí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.